[Music]
ET can confirm the California girl is
gearing up to travel across the pond May
7 to perform at the coordination of King
Charles the lineup includes another
American Idol hello
we caught up with Lionel Richie as he
stepped out alongside Ashton Kutcher and
Mila Kunis Robert Downey Jr and
Christina Aguilera at the Breakthrough
prize ceremony honoring science and math
luminaries Lionel spilled the tea on
their Royal duties Katie and I are going
to represent American Idol it's an honor
I've known him a long time but to be
asked is this is the whole thing what
does Preparation look like I can tell
you there's more secrecy than you've
ever could imagine in your life in other
words I know what I'm going to do but
when you ask well what is everybody else
going to do nothing finally we thought
coronation we do of course have to have
a singer Andrea Bocelli performance
it's very surprising that we're not
having more big British names performing
The Palace has however secured the huge
90s British viban take that
they're basically the British equivalent
of the Backstreet Boys Prince Harry will
be attending the coronation alone it's
his son Archie's birthday the very same
day so Megan is in fact going to be
staying home in California as for what
to watch out for with their interactions
aerosource says quote the family will be
cordial but there will be no meaningful
conversation as there's still a lack of
trust I fully expect Prince Harry to be
very much on the sidelines not so much
for Prince George the nine-year-old will
be featured front and center he's going
to be one of King Charles's four pages
he will follow Charles down the aisle in
Westminster Abbey it's a very key role
and a big responsibility for a little
boy and on May 2nd Paramount plus will
Premiere King Charles the boy who walked
alone the documentary features new
interviews with some of his former
girlfriends
[Music]